هذه هي السلفادور اصغر دول امريكا الوسطى
مساحه واكثرها سكانا واخطرها ومن اشدها
عنفا وهؤلاء 10,000 جندي سلفادوري بكامل
عدتهم واعتدهم يحاصرون بلده صغيره لمواجهه
العصابات عصابات قوتها بقوه الدوله
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
الست ملايين ونصف المليون سما في
السلفادور يعيشون حرفيا تحت سطوه تجار
المخدرات عصابات تسيطر على البلاد خوف عنف
جريمه كل ذلك بسبب المخدرات
عام 2021 فقط
247 جريمه قتل بمعدل 18 جريمه لكل مئه الف
سنه كما سجلت اكثر من حاله اغتصاب وصدارت
قوه الجيش والشرطه اكثر من 1600 سلاح
ناريه
الف دولار
ما راس الفتراتشا وباريو 18 وغيرهما من
العصابات التي يزيد عدد اعضائها على
70,000 شخص
تخصصت في جرائم القتل والاتزاز وتجاره
المخدرات الدوله شنت فعلا حربا حقيقيا ضد
عدو داخلي
خلال اسبوعين فقط من شهر مارس عام 2022
السلطات السلفادوريه تلقي القبض على اكثر
من 9000 شخص من المنتمين لهذه العصابات
بعد حاله طوارئ اعلن عنها الرئيس نجيب
بوكيلا اثر ارتفاع كبير في جرائم القتل
بلغ ضحاياه 87 شخصا خلال يومين يومين فقط
اما في بلده سويا بانجو معقل العصابات
وحصنها العديد التي يبلغ عدد سكانها نحو
20042.000 نسمه فقط فقد طوقت بعشره الاف
شخصا من الع ورجال الشرطه حاملين اسلحه
ثقيله وخوذات السترات واقيه من الرصاص
وصلوا عبر مركبات حربيه في الاول من
ديسمبر عام 2022
لتفتيش البلده منزلا منزلا والقاء القبض
على اعضاء العصابات المطلوبين للعداله
[موسيقى]
امين
وستتبعها العديد من البلدات التي تشتهر
بسطوه العصابات وسيطرتهم عليها حسب
تصريحات للرئيس السلفادوري
58000 شخصا من المنتمين للاصابات خلال
ثمانيه اشهر فقط منذ اعلان حاله الطوارئ
كما اقر البرلمان قوانين رفعت مده العقوبه
القصوى للانتماء الى احدى العصابات الى
خمسه واربعين سنه ويعاقب القانون
السلفادوري السائل العصابات في وسائل
الاعلام
لمده تصل الى 15 عاما هذه الخطوات الامنيه
غير المسبوقه بتاعه السلطات هناك لبناء
سجن ضخم في وسط البلد يتسع لاربعين الف
مجرم
ما يحصل في سلفادور يعكس حاله تشهدها معظم
دول امريكا اللاتينيه حيث تنتشر عصابه
الجريمه والمافيا الخطيره بعض هذه
العصابات لديها قوه مذهله تشبه قوه الدول
دبابات طائرات حتى غواصات فلمن الغلبه
ستكون لها ام لسياده القانون